(snoring)
(alarm clock goes off loudly)
- Oh, god.
Oh, what the fuck?
(moaning)
Oh, where am I?
Oh, god! Jesus!
(distorted sounds and voices)
(loud belching)
Mom!
(sceams)
Oh, what time is it?
(belches)
(loud crumpling sound)
- Mmm.
(distorted sounds)
- What?
What do you want?
What are you trying to jerk off a dick?
You want to eat a dick?
What's going on?
Oh.
- It's backwash.
- Oh, I haven't been this
hung over since last weekend.
- It doesn't feel good in here, oh god.
We have to make some changes.
- Yeah.
Maybe we just stick to cider for a while.
(music swells)
I gotta shit.
- What if we just did just like a week?
- Seven days is nothing, dude.
It's gotta be like 30.
(puke sound)
(burp sound)
Oh my god!
Could you not do thirty days?
- Fuck you, I can!
- I don't want to go 30
days without eating junk!
But, I'm going to do it.
I can do it.
We can do it.
No drinking and no junk
food, we can do it.
- You know what?
Fine.
- Okay
- Let's do it.
- Yeah, let's fucking do it.
- Yeah, let's do it!
30 days!
Starting today
- What?
- In three,
- Hold on!
- Two
- I'm not ready!
- One.
Let's go.
- We forgot it was Game
of Thrones tonight!
- It's my mom's birthday!
Happy birthday, mom, call me back.
- It's raining!
- What is a coffee without
a biscotti, Biscotti Palace,
good point!
It's my neighbors bat mitzvah!
- It's a bar mitsvah.
- Oy, vey!
- It's the first day of spring.
What am I gonna not get free italian ice?
Ya idiot.
- I obviously had to drink the
- I couldn't help it.
- the beer
- he opened the chips
- They were out of salads, I swear.
- He bought it for me.
- Hey, I'm Mark.
- Don't talk to me.
- Gabby Douglas eats pizza all
the time, so I'm her today.
Shut up.
- Okay. It looks like I have 30 days free,
coming up in June, 2028.
- That's great.
That is fantastic, just
send me a cal invite.
- Why did you make us do this?
- Well, we didn't do it.
- Right.
- If anything we just
proved that we couldn't.
- I really don't like myself right now.
- I don't like who I've become.
- But I like you!
- I like you, too.
- I like you.
(both singing off key)
- I, no.
- I
- Hmmm.
I ...
You ...
Let's go to Big Wings.
- K.